[Música]
oi meu nome é nicole eu tenho dez anos a
gente falar sobre a paz interior
o que a paz interior é um estado de
tranqüilidade mental é aceitar as
dificuldades diárias com a harmonia para
atingirmos bem estar emocional a vida
aos desafios
muitas vezes eles são internos e para
interpretarmos isso precisamos de
serenidade progresso diária para isso é
necessário voltar da harmonia entre
mente e corpo
bom pessoal como exemplo o filme kung fu
panda 2 muito conhecido por todos nós
está fazendo intercâmbio dos temas
principais vamos assistir a um trecho do
filme
[Aplausos]
a pá a vida interior
estava treinando nós sem nós
sobremaneira a propriedade
isto está mal é gostoso e aí vocês acham
que é fácil encontrar a paz interior
vamos começar a praticar vou dar algumas
dicas de como conseguir mos a fase
anterior
entender e aceitar que todos nós somos
diferentes
bom na minha peça de teatro o tema
principal é a diferença e com isso
aprendi que há muitos estilos diferentes
e que não podemos jogar outra pessoa por
seu estilo de igual ao nosso
pratique o perdão se algum amigo já
tinha desagradou chat world chegou
esquece perdoe pois a vida curta para
ficarmos guardando momentos ruins
aceite o que não pode mudar
se você faz de tudo o que podia tudo a
seu alcance o seu melhor e nada mudou
então aceite que coisas ou situações
também foi mal na série como estão e se
adapte à mineira conviver com elas
medite regularmente todos nós precisamos
de um tempo sozinho sem influência para
avançar nos refletindo sobre a vida
sempre agradece as coisas boas no
veículo mundo inteiro porque tem muita
coisa pra fazer porque tem muita lição
de casa ou porque têm que acordar cedo
ou até mesmo porque o que você queria
não deu certo pelo menos agradecer por
estarmos vivos e ainda sobre o filme
vamos ver
najem pouco conseguiu a paz interior
os drones
o mundo como o chip não sei vou manter
nos quadros rio e nos ombros como
encontras de la paz que o tek tetos
padres todos os demais pt fica triste
por bilhão
esses acostagem nas cicatrizes ana não
mas se a tó nas referidas ana
assim o icasa na cicatriz e também não
interessa que haga na cicatriz deveria
assim e nem sequer errar tudo isso é
passado porque simplesmente não importa
o único que importa e sim do que tu
decides convertê e aí vocês viram que
não é possível encontrar a paz interior
é obrigada